Це контрольно-пропускний пункт "Сеньківка"  в Чернігівській області.
Тут, як і вздовж інших частин кордону з Росією
в Луганській, Чернігівській та Харківській областях
зводять мур та риють окопи.
Коли проект "стіна" завершать - точно не відомо через перебої з фінансуванням.
Держприкордонслужба має витратити цьогоріч 500 мільйонів гривень на стіну.
Утім це лише 55 відсотків від суми, що необхідна на цей рік.
Україна - не єдина країна, що зводить мур на кордоні з Росією через її агресію.
Литва у червні 2017 року розпочала будівництво паркану
вздовж сухопутних кордонів з Калінінградською областю РФ
Планується, що двометрову металеву огорожу встановлять до грудня.
Вартість – один мільйон триста тисяч євро.
Тим часом у Латвії будують найдовший паркан на кордоні з Росією - 193 кілометри.
Роботи планують завершити у 2019 році.
Естонія також будує паркан завдовжки майже 100 км на кордоні з Росією.
Водний кордон позначать буйками
Посилення прикордонної зони коштуватиме Естонії 74 млн євро.
А от у Норвегії у вересні 2016 року збудували паркан на кордоні з РФ
щоб захиститися від нелегальної міграції
Адже у 2015 році до країни через цей контрольно-пропускний пункт прибули 5500 біженців.